all right so Andor episode 4 is out now
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down the story some of the
Easter eggs that you probably missed are
theories for next episode and also our
reaction and review of this episode last
week we left Cassian battling it out
with the corporate Authority learned of
his qunari origin story and saw him
leaving pharynx with luthin into Parts
Unknown still having a clue why luthan
wanted Andor I mean maybe it's uh like
Star Wars version of Taken Liam Neeson I
mean I mean Qui-Gon where are you buddy
now if you enjoyed this video then
please Force push that like button and
also don't forget to subscribe for
reviews and Recaps like this every week
with that out of the way a huge thank
you for clicking this now let's get into
Andor episode 4.
foreign
[Music]
this week picks up immediately after
that escape as we learn more about what
luthin actually wants with Cassian
offering him an almost opportunity to do
something much bigger than his life than
scraping by day to day this is a similar
call to the rebel cause that we've seen
a handful of other times in previous
Star Wars projects with Andor recruiting
gin erso in Rogue one Obi-Wan did it to
Luke Ezra Bridger got something similar
and it's sort of like poetry they rhyme
through this conversation we discovered
that they are headed to the planet of
aldani while Cassian Reveals His path to
fighting on Min band and how The Empire
had them fighting themselves now two
interesting things are that Min band was
the gruesome looking battle that was
featured in Solo a Star Wars story so
this giant Universe it ain't so big
after all but that the Empire's tactics
of oppressing the Galaxy and using
themselves against one another had been
instilled for decades the job casting is
recruited for is finally revealed being
five days big Stakes a prep team with a
good plan and paying 200
000 credits
smash cut over to Coruscant the capital
of the Galaxy which is heavily shown in
the prequel films being this almost new
york-esque Metropolis that is home to
important Star Wars locations like the
Jedi Council the Senate and of course
dex's Diner but instead of grabbing some
Jawa juice we head over to the Imperial
Security Bureau or the ISB who just
won't let the rebels be they're gonna
shut him down on adani yeah I'm probably
getting fired for that one anyway the
ISB is the Central Intelligence and law
enforcement agency for the entire
Galactic Empire started shortly after
the New Order rule of the emperor with a
handful of Agents growing exponentially
in size as they they now run a majority
of the Galaxy this is where we are
introduced to a new character of Debra
Miro in what appears to be an imperial
debriefing room it showcased that the
Imperials are wearing all white lack any
sense of fashion or color showing how
order is maintained with no personality
allowed or stepping out of line it's
gathered through these debriefings that
the ISB isn't necessarily involved in
law enforcement but rather Healthcare
stomping out germs being the remedy for
anyone or anything that may cause A
disruption this obviously being a
metaphor for viruses and how they view
the rebels their ideology spreads like a
cancer to the Imperials constantly
growing and infecting people to turn
against their oppressors which we saw an
inkling of in the first three episodes
of Andor the conflict on pharynx is
brought out by Lieutenant supervisor
blevin played by Ben Bailey Smith AKA
Doc Brown uh no no no no uh he's he's
actually a rapper and comedian some of
his stuff's not bad anyway he discusses
how the incident was botched by the
corporate Authority agents with ferricks
and the entire morlana system now
shifting control from the corpose to
permanent Imperial Authority AKA
Stormtroopers be patrolling the streets
hide your kids hide your wife they
snatching up everyone there's a final
tease from one of the Imperial officers
mentioning that there has been an
increase in construction shipments to
the planet of scarif got a nice Rogue
one tease folks because scarif is where
the finale of that film takes place
transmitting the Death Star plans to the
rebels and also where andor's story
comes to a close yeah he he did spoiler
alert back on aldani Andor cleans up
shaving his beard which both ironically
makes him look a lot more like his
wanted hologram from the previous
episodes but also symbolizes that he is
back on the path of scum and villainy
and in a sense he's breaking the law in
the eyes of you know the Empire once
again taking on the name of Clem for the
next five days to protect his identity
which is a nice callback that I
completely missed in episode 3 but Clem
is the name of his adoptive father that
we saw looting the ship with Marva
further conversation with luthin reveals
him handing over a kyber crystal to
Andor as essentially a down payment for
the job now if you're a big fan you know
kyber crystals are what powers
lightsabers a Jedi's apprenticeship saw
them searching for one themselves
commonly on planets of Elam or Jeddah
bonding with the force user to give the
Crystal and lightsaber its signature
color the kyber having a sky blue color
rather than it being clear and Lutheran
firmly saying that he wants it back when
this whole job is done and over with
makes me believe that he could be an
ex-jedi wouldn't that be a twist of fate
hey it could happen we've seen crazier
things in the Star Wars universe
there's a hooded figure making their way
to the ship similar to Obi-Wan but also
wearing a poncho that looks very similar
to the ones that Cal kestus wears in the
Jedi Fallen order video game I honestly
thought it was going to be castis at
first but hey we're one step closer to
getting him in live action folks I'm
just curious who would actually play
this character I mean he doesn't he
doesn't really look like anyone also the
cockpit of Luth and ship also has a
striking similarity to the Millennium
Falcon especially when jumping to
hyperspace earlier it is interesting
because Vel oh I completely forgot this
is this is Val sartha leader of the
ragtag group of people Lutheran has kind
of put together for this Mission which
has apparently been going on for five
months or there's been five months of
planning so it is pretty jarring to
bring Andor into the mix essentially
three days before it's supposed to go
down anyway Vel does mention aldani used
to be this robust Countryside before the
Empire took control roughly a decade
earlier expanding that aldani is the
perfect hub for distribution aldani has
the unfortunate quality of being close
to nothing and not very far away from
everything it's the perfect hub for
distribution
if one we're trying to take over the
Galaxy Vel mentions that there are still
a few Shepherds nature lovers Mystics
dead Enders guys named Frank in the
Hills which makes me want to say that
Jedi or potentially force-sensitive
individuals are hiding out on this
planet meaning the dilapidated
structures could have been old Jedi
lodging and the Stone Temple that the
crew mentions in their plan at the end
of this episode is an old Jedi Temple
much like everyone in this operation is
told only the information that they need
it is revealed that Andor is on this job
and they're stealing the entire
quarterly payroll from the Imperials
that's it but it actually is from a huge
Imperial Armory and Garrison again
carrying similarities from Rogue one
here this feels like a suicide mission
as we now see the planet is patrolled by
Tie fighters from the air bases close by
adding to the minimal success of this
job and the fear that the Empire has
over the cowardine people in the galaxy
Lutheran is now off to Coruscant and we
learn a bit more about his character as
we see this literal transformation of
scoundrel untrustworthy seed of the
Rebellion to this Fancy Pants fake
smiling Elite wearing gold rings and
bracelets acting very Regal and snooty
with his hand movements like oh look at
me I'm so fancy it's a massive
transformation from episode 3 and kind
of reminds me of Bruce Wayne's Playboy
Persona in the Nolan Batman trilogy but
after this transformation we can see
that this Persona is actually the fake
one as the fake Joy is entirely sucked
out of him when he's done and ready
there's two blue moons on the horizon of
aldani that look like the Dual sons of
tattooing as were then introduced to a
couple of the other Rebels on this crazy
Mission both Karis nemic and Arville
Skeen I know it's Star Wars but man I
cannot pronounce these names give me
give me a bill or or a Ted I don't know
something easy but they are played by
Alex lother and Eben Moss backrank who I
thought would just be yelling about
Italian beef orders because I just saw
him in the bear and chef's kiss nemic
was caught sleeping saint of Saw
Guerrero was there he would have his
head on a pike saw Guerrero who we know
is played by Forest Whitaker is a major
player in the rebellion and known for
his gorilla tactics an aggressive
approach to fighting the empire in live
action he's in Rogue one but also
featured throughout a lot of Star Wars
properties from the Clone Wars to Rebels
the bad batch along with a handful of
novels so it seems that these pockets of
rebels are isolated but do have contact
with one another or at least knowing of
the major players in the game at Camp
the other two members that make up the
small group of rebels are terramen
barcana and Sinta Cass as it further
shows that every member of this group is
a bit shocked by the arrival of Andor
and that keeping information from one
another may be the downfall of this up
upcoming operation Karn appears to be
discharged from the corporate Authority
ever since it was totally taken over by
Imperial control and I'm taking this
situation as almost a dishonorable
discharged in a sense because he's
returning home it has this depressing
feeling with his mother slapping him
when he returns she does have a very
similar hairstyle to what Leia is
wearing in the Last Jedi meaning that
hairstyles have not changed in about 40
years I thought for sure Karn would play
a much bigger role climbing the ranks so
I'm curious if he's out of the corporate
sector but going to join the Imperial
Academy straight up in the next few
episodes luthin's day-to-day Persona is
finally revealed like we thought he is
this Rich Elite being an antique stealer
dealing with some rare and unique items
just a handful of items around his shop
is the best scar Mandalorian armor that
we've seen old Mando wear in the
Mandalorian series a small dagger that
looks similar to the mortise Dagger from
the Clone Wars a gungan field from the
Battle of Naboo in the back I bet you're
thinking really something let's see that
one so uh yeah you're welcome but also
these Stone glyphs look similar to The
Meditation circles from Jedi Fallen
order but going one further these two
that have the Fist and the open hand
look like they are straight out of the
Fallen orders upgrade skill tree a
circle with the symbol in the middle now
either of these two symbols are actually
upgrades in the game but they are
leaning heavy into that Jedi Temple lore
and the symbols from the game it could
be a long shot but never tell me the
odds meeting with luthan is mon mothma
who again is a high-ranking member of
the Rebellion that we do see in the
later films feature to be in the
planning of the events in Rogue one and
also the battle of the Death Star part 2
as she opposed the policies of the
Supreme Chancellor Palpatine as the
leader of the galactic Senate's loyalist
faction so we're getting her at a time
where she's still pulling power from the
Senate while also trying to sparked the
Rebellion on the side through
conversations here with Lutheran we
discovered that their relationship is
very secretive not really like a
cheating Affair type thing but rather
you know she is bankrolling the
operations of Lutheran that he has going
on with Andor and the others it sounds
like they've been planning this in
private for a while but it's a losing
cause almost two steps forward and one
step back now one interesting thing MAF
must suggest is that she's found another
person that she thinks she can bring
into the circle to help with the
Rebellion who is this mystery man or
Mystery Woman maybe is only a guess my
first thought was Leia but at this time
in the story she's only 14 years old so
not sure how much of an influence she
may actually have and I get it Padme was
only 14 years old in Phantom Menace blah
blah blah but you know what time's a
change in folks the government's run by
some creepy man with unlimited power
wait a minute my guess is bail Organa
who then will eventually bring Leia on
board it feels like the right way to
usher in and kind of connect these two
stories either way I am assuming that
this Lutheran relationship will continue
through the show because she only takes
the artifact on loan and she'll
essentially be back at some point with
Luther insane I trust you'll have the
courage to turn back it should be a bit
much my guess is that after the Andor
Mission goes sideways they go into full
panic mode with the ISB slowly breathing
down their necks and their plans are
foiled because of the increasing number
of Imperial spies that are keeping a
close eye on mothma lastly Lieutenant
Gorn is the final member of the Attack
Force to be revealed an inside man
working for the Empire arriving on a
Speeder bike that looks and sounds
eerily similar to the Speeders from
Endor
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
probably tuned for more Lush and
forested areas than the desert Speeders
that we've seen in you know other series
anyway they run through the plan which
is a drastic contrast to what we've seen
the rebels debriefing stations look like
in other films and projects the original
trilogy saw this clean pristine
debriefing with screens while Rogue ones
took a step back still having a hollow
deck to explain everything while andors
is made of sticks and rocks showing the
shoestring budget that they are working
with and how this job is going to be
pulled off with pure skill and honestly
a lot of luck Vel goes over the plan
mentioning the Empire took control of
this sacred land roughly 13 years
earlier claiming it for the emperor name
drop we got a name drop here the empire
was interested in the caverns because of
their unique storage capabilities along
with a vault being built into the cavern
the first thing that came to mind when
they were talking about the emperor and
vaults is the Emperor vaults that he had
hid all around the Galaxy see of what
showed up in the final mission of Star
Wars Battlefront 2. so this could be one
holding more than just the payroll
credits there could be something else in
there for them to steal anyway they run
down the plan saying that they will bust
into the Armory head into the Vault with
Andor essentially piloting a flying
shipping crate out of a single runway in
and out of the Vault and fly to safety
with the payload Andor claims that this
is honestly impossible this you know
what guys this isn't gonna work I am out
of here because the Tie fighters will be
on them in minutes when then Gore
reveals the second phase of the plan
saying that he will have a moment to
escape in what is called the eye of
agamoto no no no no that that's that's
not right the eye of aldani which is a
massive meteor shower Illuminating the
entire Sky allowing them a small window
to escape that's the plan it's it sounds
awful but that's the plan as Andor
further studies the specs to catch up on
everything thing to get prepared for the
next day now I'm expecting the next
couple of episodes to be this explosive
Ocean's 11 Heist playing out similar to
the trench run in a new hope it's a
suicide mission but a small task force
can probably pull it off however there's
going to be some sort of Hiccup or
information that is kept from Andor as
he's the one to be blamed for all of it
again going back to what luthan
mentioned a Vel Andor is essentially a
mercenary therefore he is disposable
though I don't think Lutheran has any
ill intentions they need a Fall Guy in
case the Empire is on their scent Andor
will end up being the one that is this
guy and he'll wind up in some Imperial
Detention Center either learning more
information that he didn't know before
finding more Rebels for the cause or
somehow escaping my Republic credits now
are on him escaping although I enjoyed
the origin story set up the first three
episodes of Andor episode 4 seems to be
getting in the ball rolling in where and
what the whole main mission of Andor is
going to be not only is it perfectly
setting up this Rogue one suicide
mission aspect but building out the core
cast into their own micro story lines is
what's really kind of hooking me through
this right now seeing the problems
luthin mafma Deidra Khan are all dealing
with and how it's going to be tying back
to the main mission here has me
intrigued it feels like there's some
real Stakes here with each of the
characters having their own motivations
in the Star Wars world that that is a
tongue twister while exploring
everything from the feeble Rebels to the
rich Elites the power hungry politicians
and the corrupt Empire but obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on Andor
episode 4 and if this series is going
that Rogue One Direction that you were
hoping for now get this we are currently
running a competition giving away three
copies of Thor love and thunder on the
15th of October and all you have to do
to have a chance of winning this is like
this video make sure to subscribe with
notifications on and drop your comments
on this episode of Andor we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and of the winners of last month's
drawing are on screen right now if
that's you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other videos right over there
whether it be our house of dragon
breakdowns or Rick and Morty season 6
coverage with that out of the way thanks
for sticking through this video I've
been Jared and I gotta go study some
aldani phrases so I'll see you in the
next one take care and peace